show the article i just sent you about
recession
you you tell me how this reads i just
texted it to you okay
so you would think like okay
they're going to talk about recession
and they're going to say different
opinions and they're going to say well
people disagree and it's gonna be a
reasonable route nope look at look at
this title actually zoom in
who decides if the us is in recession
eight white economists you've never
heard of what what what
what do you mean eight what does white
have to do with recession and this is
scene and you wonder like you wonder why
people are sick of your
games
just say eight economists you've never
heard of before that that one word white
is why people are sick of you that one
simple because it's that's exactly this
division that's exactly how you get
people angry to think the white people
are saying there's a recession can you
go up a little bit go up a little bit
let's actually read this article to see
how it's written oh open it up a little
bit zoom in a little bit more so i say
the the people's names probably yeah
prominent wall street uh economists like
uh mark zandy investing luminaries like
arkansas cattywood and uh kathy wood and
executives like jpmorgan chase jamie
diamond can make recession predictions
until they're blue in the face but their
guidance will remain just at an economic
forecast that's because in the united
states the economy isn't broadly
unofficially considered to be a
recession until a relatively unknown
group of eight economists say so the
economists who serve together as
business cycle dating committee are hand
selected by the working under umbrella
of that national bureau of economic
research a private nonprofit
organization they're they are they have
no predetermined meeting dates and their
deliberations are i mean what what are
you what are you saying and look at it
there's no recession unless these guys
say so yeah
that's that's the one right there
there's a clear lack of racial diversity
among the eight members it's race
cnn yeah when it comes down to recession
there is no color
then nobody says well in order for us to
finalize recession we need to have one
black one hispanic one iranian somebody
from the lgbtq that's the only way
recession is real stop playing these
games no and if you want to pull
ridiculous when they do this
so ridiculous when they do this and by
the way
keep doing it
keep doing it if you forgot why cnn plus
didn't work with 300 million dollars in
small little startups like you know uh
what's ben shapiro's company's name
daily wireless and you got these other
companies that are coming up they're
whooping your ass
and it's not gonna slow down by the way
you keep playing games with americans
who just want some information and you
keep trying to say it's division
right what a pathetic article right
you're trying to create division i'm uh
one pathetic article right there i'm 100
agreements with you 100 they're playing
identity politics like why why even
listen i don't care if you're blue i
don't care if you're at red when it
comes to the economy it's all about the
green you're playing identity politics
like i don't just ten leading economists
eight leading economists said this
period i don't care if they're black
white yellow green jewish catholic like
give me some give me some actual
substance what's the next next eight
they're five eight and under like how
they're gonna talk about height it's
like bro relax bro that's insane it's
too much you see when you do stuff like
that none of these people say anything
gases and eight bucks a gallon in l.a
okay what are your thoughts on this it
says americans account for 13 of the us
population but only three percent okay
of economists
wait a minute wait a minute okay let's
play that right let's play that game
sure can you can you tell me uh uh white
people account for
60 of the population yet only 11 of the
nba
yeah you're right is the nba racist yeah
why don't you let white people play
there uh america accounts for 24
hispanic but the nba is only one percent
hispanic what a racist organization i
think less than one percent but what i'm
trying to say to you is
see when but by the way
a comment like that
for people who
don't really really read into it they're
like oh that's right [ __ ] racist
deserve to be more black economists
guess guess what go become an economy by
the way it is way easier to become an
economist than it is to become an nba
player one thousand just so you know
yeah one thousand percent
yeah they're they're done bro it's like
i like the analogy you just gave there
because anyone with their head on
straight will be like well yeah
obviously because you know they're not
like
as good as the tall seven foot black
guys playing basketball yeah you just
because of your color or your belief or
your belief system you don't deserve a
job yeah it's a product
meritocracy
yeah i'm 100 with you on pat it's
annoying as hell so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]